handschlag in genf russlands präsident
putin und us-präsident beiden sprechen
miteinander und über das zerrüttete
verhältnis beider staaten zu groß zu
teuer zu bürokratisch fragezeichen die
umstrittenen impfzentren soll es auch
über september hinaus geben missglückte
aktionen in münchen die deutsche
mannschaft konzentriert sich nach dem
eigentor gestern aufs nächste spiel an
einer gefährlichen greenpeace-aktion
hagelt es kritik
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers ihn einen guten abend
zum blick auf diesen nachrichten
mittwoch wir freuen uns dass sie dabei
sind und kristin otto hat nachher den
sport neben fußball auch tennis guten
abend inmitten diplomatische eiszeit ein
besonderer gipfel heute in genf das
erste persönliche treffen von wladimir
putin und joe biden seit beiden
amtsantritt absolut konstruktiv sei das
gespräch verlaufen sagt russlands
präsident und zu bereden gab es genug
denn die beziehungen der beiden staaten
sind so schlecht wie lange nicht ein
streitpunkt die usa werfen russland seit
jahren vor sich gezielt in wahlen
einzumischen auch in die amerikanischen
der konflikt um die ost ukraine ist ein
weiterer streitpunkt ebenso wie der fall
navalny und die verletzung von
menschenrechten in russland aus genf
berichtete matti wissen es scheint als
wäre er ganz zufrieden nach vier stunden
gipfeltreffen steigt schon beiden in die
limousine und fährt davon in ein nahe
gelegenes hotel für seine
pressekonferenz
begonnen hatte der nachmittag an
gleicher stelle mit händeschütteln beide
staaten führer wollten signalisieren
dass die wege suchen zur verständigung
gemeinsam mit ihren außenministern
besprachen sie die heißen eisen den
konflikt um die ost ukraine
hacker-angriffe
menschenrechtsverletzungen aber auch
chancen zur zusammenarbeit beim
klimaschutz unter einem neuen
abrüstungsvertrag es habe dabei keine
feindseligkeiten gegeben so wladimir
putin bei seiner pressekonferenz aber
meinungsverschiedenheiten
wir haben unterschiedliche
einschätzungen bei vielen themen aber
beide seiten zeigten bereitschaft sich
gegenseitig zu verstehen gemeinsamkeiten
zu suchen
die gespräche waren konstruktiv man
werde verhandlungen führen zur abrüstung
zum kampf gegen cyberattacken und den
klima werde ihr präsident biden habe
auch die menschenrechte angesprochen
aber putin verteidigte das vorgehen
gegen oppositionelle wie alexei navalny
er habe das gesetz gebrochen
die beiden präsidenten vereinbarten dass
ihre botschafter wieder auf ihre posten
zurückkehren um die diplomatischen
beziehungen schnellstmöglich zu
normalisieren
gleich wird hier auch der amerikanische
präsident die ergebnisse aus seiner
sicht bewerten aber eines steht schon
fest der genfer gipfel war nicht das
ende der gespräche zwischen russland und
den usa
dann bringen wir jetzt unsere russland
und usa korrespondenten mit dazu zuerst
zu für begangene vilbel die putins
pressekonferenz gerade ganz genau
verfolgt hat was will der russische
präsident denn von diesem gipfel
mitnehmen also präsident putin wirkte
schon erleichtert und auch gelassen auf
dieser pressekonferenz
er sprach eben von einem konstruktiven
gespräch und nannte präsident biden
wiederum einen erfahrenen politiker
allerdings hat er den hauptteil der
pressekonferenz damit verbracht seine
altbekannten positionen zu verteidigen
und das auch sehr vehement hat er zum
beispiel danach gefragt wurde ob denn
die repressionen gegen die russische
oppositionspolitiker ob sie auch eine
rolle gespielt haben bei dem gipfel da
sagte putin in sachen menschenrechten da
müssen die usa doch erst mal vor der
eigenen haustür kehren und die
cyber-attacken die sache gar nicht als
russisches thema an seine putin sagte
dass während dieser gespräche kein druck
ausgeübt worden wäre weder von der
russischen noch von der amerikanischen
delegation im umkehrschluss kann man
daraus vielleicht folgern dass er diese
klare kante die sich joe biden für den
gipfel vorgenommen hatte
dass die den russischen präsidenten
nicht sonderlich beeindruckt hat guten
abend dauern elmar theveßen immer eine
rote linie wollte joe biden markieren
gegenüber dem russischen präsidenten ist
ihm das gelungen
also wenn er das getan hat in den
gesprächen ist es bei putin jedenfalls
nicht angekommen wenn man die
pressekonferenz vor hin verfolgt hat und
joe biden hat jetzt in der tat ein
großes problem er muss im grunde
genommen ein anderes bild der
wirklichkeit zeichnen als das was war
die mir putin vorhin vorgetragen hat
denn er hat den vielen punkten jede
verantwortung abgewiesen und abgelehnt
oder das sind genau die punkte
die joe biden ja vorher eben gespräch
wirklich einbringen wollte als er
braucht einen sehr starken auftritt um
zu verhindern dass in den usa die
überschriften laufen dass wladimir putin
ihn über den tisch gezogen hat das kann
er nur wenn er neben den tatsächlichen
darstellungen was er gesagt hat auch
klarmachen kann
zu welchen zugeständnissen russland
bereit gewesen ist nur dann macht
eigentlich auch die fortsetzung von
gesprächen sinn wenn eben eine
bereitschaft auf putin seiten ebenfalls
vorhanden ist also so beiden steht jetzt
unter druck oder er kann nicht nach
hause gehen ohne auch wirklich etwas
konkretes vorzuweisen
interessante analyse ganz herzlichen
dank nach genf unser nächstes thema
heute abend beginnt erstmal mit den
corona zahlen für deutschland und da es
bemerkenswert mit der neuen delta
variante des erregers stecken sich auch
hierzulande immer mehr menschen an
der anteil hat sich nach jüngsten zahlen
fast verdoppelt auf gut 6 prozent der
infektionen
die gesamtzahlen das robert koch
institut meldet 1455 neuinfektionen
innerhalb eines tages das sind 1799
weniger als letzten mittwoch 137
menschen starben in zusammenhang mit
cupid 19 in den vergangenen 24 stunden
die sieben tage incidents sinkt deutlich
auf 13,2 die inzidenz sinkt die
impfquote steigt gestern hatten rund
950.000 menschen einen impftermin
schauen wir mal genauer hin
seit dezember wurden 67,6 millionen
impfdosen verteilt davon gingen zwei
drittel an impfzentren ein drittel an
arztpraxen und betriebsärzte
mittlerweile hat sich das umgekehrt
in der vergangenen woche gab es 6,2
millionen dosen und davon ging nur ein
drittel an die zentren zwei drittel
vererbten praxen und betriebe braucht
man also die vergleichsweise teuren
impfzentren überhaupt noch frage an die
gesundheitsminister heute alexander pohl
die auslastung der impfzentren in
deutschland ist unterschiedlich hier in
aachen gibt es noch reichlich
kapazitäten allein es fehlt an impfstoff
eine mögliche schließung des imf
zentrums sieht man hier äußerst kritisch
wenn es keine impfzentren mehr gibt dann
bleiben natürlich nur die arztpraxen
und da wird es mit den klassischen
hausarztpraxen alleine gar nicht zu
bewältigen seien
dem widersprechen die hausärzte sie
sehen ihre praxen als am besten fürs
impfen gerüstet und halten die
impfzentren für verzichtbar
wir berichten hier sehr ineffiziente
strukturen die ja für eine impfung da
fast das zehnfache als kosten
verursachen kosten die der bund noch bis
zum 30 september mittragen will
wie es danach weitergeht darüber gab es
heute keine einigung
bundesgesundheitsministerin sparen kann
sich eine weitergehende mitfinanzierung
der impfzentren vorstellen da sozusagen
die richtige balance zu finden nichts zu
sehen
eine struktur zu finanzieren die erstmal
nicht gebraucht wird der code aber
gleichzeitig in der lage zu sein schnell
hochzufahren und deswegen eine gewisse
vorhalte struktur zu haben
das ist das worum wir jetzt einfach ein
kompromiss noch mal anders definieren
wollen
bayerns gesundheitsminister indes ist
von der notwendigkeit der impfzentren
überzeugt lieber diese dinge vorhalten
und dann sofort impfen zu können als nur
ein paar tage impfstoff zu haben und
keine struktur in den kommenden zwei
wochen wollen die gesundheitsminister
der länder eine lösung für die
impfzentren erarbeiten 132.000 euro in
mehreren tranchen überwiesen anonym aus
der schweiz an den kreisverband der
jetzigen spitzenkandidatin der afg alice
weiter unzulässig hatte der bundestag
gesagt und verhängte ein bußgeld von
knapp 400.000 euro das berliner
verwaltungsgericht bestätigt jetzt dass
die partei dieses bußgeld zahlen muss
und wies eine klage der afd dagegen ab
christiane hübscher berichtet alice
weidl ist selbst nicht vor ort als das
gericht seine entscheidung verkündet die
partei muss die hohe strafzahlungen für
eine illegale spende akzeptieren das
parteiengesetz stellt im interesse der
transparenz sehr hohe anforderungen an
die zulässigkeit von parteispenden und
danach ist es unter anderem unzulässig
parteispenden anzunehmen die von
unbekannter herkunft sind
und gegen diesen grundsatz hat die afg
verstoßen
die fdp-spitzenkandidatin wird eingeholt
von einer anonymen wahlkampfspende aus
dem jahr 2017 die 132.000 euro aus der
schweiz kamen in tranchen gestückelt
erst monate später hat die partei das
geld zurücküberwiesen zu spät sagt das
gericht weiter äußert sich heute
schriftlich gegenüber dem zdf eine junge
oppositionspartei wird für spenden die
in voller höhe zurückgezahlt wurden und
von denen kein vorteil erwachsen ist mit
der maximalen strafe belegt das ganze zu
beginn eines bundestagswahlkampfs auch
abgeordnete der fdp bundestagsfraktion
sind als zuhörer vor gericht dabei
manche fordern schon konsequenzen für
weiter ich glaube da gibt es viele
mitglieder die da schon erwarten dass
jemand der einen fehler macht unter
durch strafzahlungen verschuldet dass
der auch dafür zumindest teilweise auf
kommt natürlich ist es so dass ein eine
unklarheit in finanziellen dingen immer
zu glaubwürdigkeitsverlust in einer
partei führt fast 400.000 euro strafe
muss die fdp nun zahlen
die partei behält sich vor in berufung
zu gehen der antisemitismus ist eine der
größten bedrohungen für die sicherheit
in deutschland sagt bundesinnenminister
horst seehofer er berät aktuell mit den
innenministern der länder was sie
dagegen tun können und sie müssen sich
auch mit ungenauigkeiten in der
statistik befassen
danach hat die polizei bundesweit im
letzten jahr 2351 antisemitische
straftaten registriert fast alle werden
dann quasi automatisch dem rechten
spektrum zugeordnet egal wer sie konkret
begangen hat anna wassberg und simon
pfanzelt berichten
es ist nicht der erste angriff auf die
ulmer synagoge und wieder weiß rabbiner
schnitttechnik nicht wer hier vor zwei
wochen den brand gelegt hat neben dem
fleck bleibt ein gefühl der unsicherheit
erst mal ich hoffe dass wir irgendwann
mal wissen werden wer dahinter steckt
aber es geht nicht nur um die frage wer
dahinter steckt so dass die tatsache
dass man angegriffen
sie sind allein in diesem jahr sollen
619 von bisher 7 104 antisemitischen
straftaten in deutschland von
rechtsextremisten verübt worden sein
auf der volg dieser statistische
zuordnung wenn sich keine gegenteiligen
anhaltspunkte ergeben das wollen einige
innenminister jetzt ändern
nach meiner auffassung brauchen wir eine
valide und klare datengrundlage es gibt
freilich auch antisemitismus aus dem
linksextremistischen bereich aus dem
ausländerextremismus und
selbstverständlich auch aus dem
islamismus kommen die statistik soll
präziser werden aber das problem bleibt
oft können taten nicht komplett aus
ermittelt werden
das wird schlicht so bleiben dass wir
einen haufen von fällen haben werden bei
denen wir wissen es ist ein
antisemitischer hintergrund gegeben bei
denen wir aber am ende noch nicht sagen
können woher die motivlage rührt im
kampf gegen antisemitismus wünscht sich
sabina stör trap nicht mehr
präventionsmaßnahmen stadt statistiken
die spuren von brand will er erstmal
nicht verwischen als erinnerung in
berlin spitzt sich die lage um einen
teilweise besetztes haus im stadtteil
friedrichshain zu
bei einer auseinandersetzung zwischen
anhängern der linksradikalen szene und
der polizei wurden 60 beamte verletzt
etwa 200 vermummte hatten vor dem haus
in der rigaer straße barrikaden
angezündet und die polizei mit steinen
und böllern attackiert auslöser der
eskalation morgen ist in dem haus eine
behördliche brandschutz prüfung geplant
sie wird jetzt mit tausend
polizeibeamten abgesichert
für genug spannung war gesorgt gestern
abend vor dem ersten em spiel der
deutschen mannschaft gegen frankreich
aber dann gab es noch einmal zusätzlich
aufregung und sorge aus einem ganz
anderen grund
bei der weltweiten fernsehübertragungen
hier kurz im bild oben zu sehen ein
motor gleitschirm trudelt ins münchner
stadion auf dem feld spricht
nationalspieler antonio rüdiger kurz mit
dem greenpeace aktivisten bei dessen
aktion zwei menschen verletzt wurden
heute viel kritik und viele fragen an
greenpeace claudia vogelmann und luton
liners als der motor gleitschirm über
der arena auftaucht halten das viele
zunächst für eine showeinlage
schließlich wirft der pilot ja einen
ball nach unten
als er wieder wegfliegen will streift
der ein teil der dachkonstruktion und
stürzte ins stadion
ein schock für viele zuschauer und
spieler erinnerungen an den
terroranschlag 2015 im staat de france
wir sind knapp an einer katastrophe
vorbeigeschlittert
das hätte viel schlimmer ausgehen können
wenn ihr ein drama passiert wäre
ich bin sprachlos auf der tribüne werden
zwei männer nach polizeiangaben leicht
am kopf verletzt als teile des
propellers auf dem rücken des piloten
abreißen und umherfliegen warum aber hat
der pilot eine solche gefährdung
überhaupt riskiert von einem defekten
motor ist die rede
der pilot genauso wie ich unglaublich
alle waren darüber überrascht und wenn
das irgendwie vorher absehbar gesehen
wäre dann wäre hätte der pilot dieser
aktion natürlich nicht gemacht
greenpeace steht für friedlichen
gewaltfreien protest bei der die
sicherheit dritter aber auch der der
aktivistinnen aktivisten ja immer auch
mit im mittelpunkt steht den piloten
jedoch hatten bereits scharfschützen im
visier so bayerns innenministerium zur
abwehr einer möglichen terrorgefahr
somit kann sich niemand darauf verlassen
dass die polizei da schon rücksicht
walten lässt somit noch einmal die
betonung das war extrem riskantes
manöver
greenpeace hat die polizei seit kurz vor
der protestaktion informiert worden
eine bestätigung dafür gibt es bis zur
stunde nicht und jetzt der tag danach
aus sportlicher sicht mit kristic gibt
so 1 mund abputzen und weiter der
erfolgsdruck auf die deutsche mannschaft
ist nach der 0 1 niederlage gegen
weltmeister frankreich in münchen und
vor dem spiel gegen europameister
portugal am samstag weiter angestiegen
erste maßnahmen aufarbeiten und
abschirmen my home is my castle heißt es
heute bei der nationalmannschaft es
herrscht katerstimmung nach einer
dienstreise die erst früh um 2 vorbei
war und mehr fragen als antworten nach
sich zieht es geht dabei weniger darum
wie dieses unglückliche eigentor von
mats hummels passieren konnte sondern
eher um die frage warum die deutsche
mannschaft nur eine echte torchancen
zustande brachte das einzige was wir
haben kein tor erzielt und haben vorne
vielleicht auch so manchmal in manchen
situationen nochmals die
durchschlagskraft ein bisschen vermissen
lassen
katerstimmung auch bei den fans egal ob
im stadion oder draußen im biergarten
ist schon sehr enttäuschend weil wir
einfach lieber erstmal zum letzten punkt
nichts auf die reihe bekommen haben der
trainer muss schnell antworten finden
damit aus katerstimmung wieder
zuversicht wird durch ein tolles tor der
russen dass den 1 0 endstand besiegelte
verpasste finnland am zweiten spieltag
der gruppe b den vorzeitigen einzug ins
achtelfinale
dadurch hoffen nun beide mannschaften im
letzten vorrundenspiel die krone zu
erreichen
die partie in st petersburg hart
umkämpft bereits in der dritten minute
scheint projahn palo die finnen abermals
in führung zu bringen doch der
siegtorschütze aus dem dänemark spiel
stand im abseits
in der nachspielzeit der ersten hälfte
treffen stattdessen die russen mirant
schock nach der pause gibt es noch
chancen auf beiden seiten erst pukki
dann kurz hlf doch es bleibt beim 1 0
für russland
und zum tennis überraschendes aus im
achtelfinale für rekordgewinner roger
federer beim rasenturnier in halle
der 39 jahre alte schweizer unterlag dem
19 jahre jüngeren kanadier verallia sie
in drei sätzen
als erster deutscher im viertelfinale
philipp kohlschreiber der sich mit einer
starken leistung 6 4 und 7 6 gegen porto
mio aus frankreich klar durchsetzte
morgen spielt dann alexanders wäre
und heute gibt es noch die lottozahlen
hier sind sie 1 22 25 28 37 44 die
superzahl 7 weitere gewinnzahlen wie
immer bei lotto zdf.de im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
ja wir sind mittendrin in der ersten
hitzewelle des jahres und es ist echt
heißt 30 grad und mehr wie hier am
niederrhein wer raus kann fährt
natürlich raus mit dem fahrrad und ab
ins wasser
egal ob waldsee oder innenstadt
hauptsache abkühlung vielleicht helfen
ja auch bereits diese bilder vom
bodensee dabei deutschland im hochsommer
und wie es weitergeht gleich beim wetter
direkt nach uns die hitzewelle kommt
richtig in schwung ostend ali hat die
details dann empfehle ich ihnen das
heute journal mit der kollegin marietta
slomka um 21.45 wir sehen uns morgen
wieder wenn sie mögen für heute danke
ich für das interesse und wünsche ihnen
allen einen sehr angenehmen abend
[Musik]
ein kunde und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter eine beachtliche hitzewelle
erwartet uns in den nächsten tagen mehr
regional kommt die hitze aus dem süden
das bedeutet also stramm von süd nach
nord und das fällt in den nächsten tagen
an das frontensystem hier ist nicht weit
bleibt dort eng und wird in den nächsten
tagen auf teils heftige unwetter mit
gewittern auslösen in der nacht wird es
erst einmal klar sein und recht ruhig
temperaturen sinkt dabei gerade mal auf
21 grad im westen deutschlands
es ist eine tropische nacht alles was
über ein 2 1 über 20 grad liegt ist eine
tropische nacht ähnlich ist es auch
richtung rhein main gebiet deutlich
angenehmer die nacht mit 12 bis 13 grad
im südosten deutschlands morgen erste
gewitter im westen die können durchaus
auch schon unwetterartig sein ansonsten
viel sonnenschein bei höchsten
temperaturen bis 36 grad aber schauen
sie mal die temperaturen liegen überall
über der 30 grad marke bis in den hohen
norden 26 grad an der ostsee die
kommenden tage der höhepunkt dann am
freitag mit 37 grad hitze mit heftigen
gewittern am samstag ebenfalls dann nach
osten hin und sonntag kann es sogar zu
noch stärkeren unwetter kommen damit ein
schöner abend